[Musique]
c'est
seul
les petits envahissent l'hôtel de ville
de montigny le bretonneux pour fêter
leurs droits le service jeunesse de la
commune a organisé cette journée
spéciale pour le 30e anniversaire de la
convention internationale des droits de
l'enfant
l'objectif de cette journée c'est de
sensibiliser les enfants déjà sur leurs
droits
on est quand même sur une tranche d'âge
6 12 ans je pense qu'ils ont besoin de
savoir et connaître leurs droits leur
rappeler ce que eux aussi on sait bien
aussi un moment donné de savoir ce qu'on
a de faire un état des lieux entre eux
ben non dans ma ville qu'est ce qui se
passe qu'est ce que qu'est-ce qui est
mis en place de nombreux ateliers
étaient proposés comme ce débat mené par
les membres du conseil municipal des
jeunes les enfants sont amenés à recréer
une assemblée et doivent réfléchir à des
solutions pour kamini un garçon de 10
ans harcelé à l'école ça permet de
savoir comment le conseil municipal fait
pour rechercher des trucs pour s'occuper
de la ville plus loin un autre groupe
réfléchit sur le droit de bien manger en
recréant un des logo de l'unicef ont
fruits
vous avez utilisé des fruits pour les
vitamines une pomme un quart de
clémentine des myrtilles de la cranberry
pour un personnage symbole et de leurs
droits
une journée de fête pour tous les
enfants messages importants et bien
digéré